he become careful for Allah guide him
you know you know this type of people
first let me clarify the reason I'm back
because I gave a promise to S to come
today and speak to him last week and as
a Muslims we have to try our best to
keep up our promise I came but not
here maybe no we have excuse fored to
see you that's why I said last week he
promised me please can you come this
week speak
about that's what Allah said
about said
about he was someone that fulfilled the
promise explain this verse it means that
once had a meeting with his friends and
he was waiting for him from the morning
until the evening you see so we have to
our
cont of course with action also I want
to mention something you know Subhan
Allah my dear brothers and sisters you
know whatever we're going to say every
word Allah is going to judge us for it
you with me Allah will judge us for
everything what I have noticed some
Muslims they have no sh shame to lie and
slander people all right you know Allah
even though I mentioned clearly about
boycotting you know boycotting
there's two different opions among the
scholars if you want to boycott you can
boycott boycott Starbucks boycott your
house boycott kitchen boycott your room
that's up to you some said up to you to
boycott some scholar said he goes back
to the leaders yeah but some said no you
can boycott like boycott a company
that's supporting P zist or there so one
guy what he did when I was having a live
stream he went and
light he's a evil liar he went and he
edit my video to make me look back even
though in the live stream clearly I said
if you want a boycott boycott however if
you want to boycott don't make a
composure on everyone all right because
America just gave 14 billion to the
Zionist they are Aid in the Zionist so
go out and give the American passport or
they document America I'm going to
boycot you and leave America Surrender
Your yes or come out and tell the Muslim
stop paying taxes in America because
that 14 billion is coming from taxes all
right so my point here is some Muslim
they want to force you to boycott
something when they not boyot the other
thing so I was speaking to a brother he
said to me to boycot Starbucks I said
why he said because they supp zist I
said all right if this the case be
consistent we have to be
consistent Instagram that you are using
the owner zist are you going to boycot
Instagram you see what I'm saying that's
my point someone twist my speech again
if you want to boyot boycott but let us
boycot the first thing let us boycot the
first thing what is the first thing to
boycot primary source Shan of boycot
Shan first then boycot Starbucks no more
Starbucks I'm getting this coffee I'm
good Muslim now no Starbucks with Muslim
so if you drink Starbucks you CF now
Starbucks become what make you caer or
Muslim
you see some Muslims you
know so drinking Starbucks or not
drinking Starbucks and the most
important that's why my brothers have
been saying and my sisters in a time of
hardship what is our criteria Quran
Sunnah alhamdulillah for for day one
Quran Sunnah that's why they go lie
against us s because they know Quran
alhamdulillah Allah said the messenger
of Allah sallam
alhamdulillah so I said it clearly and
they say sh is mocking brothers who are
boting
Starbucks boy I was showing the double
standard of the Muslims you live in
America America are supported zist so
why not boycotting America and go back
to your country you live in Britain
Britain are supporting zist why don't
you give up your British passport and go
back to your country if you really you
want to show the true love for the
Palestinians that's why the school said
boycotting go back to the leaders said
yes if you want to boycott you can do it
however you cannot force people if I
don't want to boycott anything that you
are boycotting don't accuse me that I'm
C because where Allah said or messenger
of said if I don't boy Starbucks I'm
careful we bringing our new
Islam this a new de and if I anyone
believe I'm wrong you are more than
welcome to correct
me because quah and I mentioned in the
live stream I mentioned two opinions
people still say is moing you know why
Muslims don't like some Muslims some are
liberal so liberals Muslims they don't
mind boycotting coffee shop but they
what they what they don't like to tell
them pray they hate it they hate Salat
cuz salad go against their liberalism so
they don't like Salat they like what let
me boycott but let me be let me be doing
this before you boycott anything boy
after boy Shan don't be the best friend
of Shan and your boy in Starbucks or
your boy in what they call Costa Coffee
when you die imagine this if you die and
you don't pray and you Bo Starbucks what
will happen to you from Allah Allah is
going to say to you are you boycot
Starbucks go
Jenna because you boycotted the Salah
yeah your
boy Allah sent your boy Sal and the
first thing we ask from day of judgment
Sal Allah going to ask about
Starbucks you see so you're a b
Starbucks Bo and B mind Starbucks is a
franchise so in the Muslim countries the
money goes to the Muslims and the
Muslims workers also get paid from it
all right likewise other companies yes
but the point here my brothers and
sisters may Allah bless you all why we
telling like this we becomeing I don't
know like we know Solutions in the Quran
and Sunnah we say no Allah I don't
believe in your solution believe I have
to to uh boot kitchen or chicken or
Burger that's how that's how we're going
to have
Philistine if you're a real person and
you want a boycott America just sent 14
billion to the Zionist and weapons leave
America be a man and if you say no I
have nowhere to go leave for the sake of
Allah you believe in Allah Allah can
give you everything leave because why
you have a fake IM and that's what those
guys are telling us to vote for you know
uman
he was going to be soft on the Muslims
is a big you know but the point this
individual is a lion because he's hurt
after expose him here no Quran Sunnah
lying what he did he's going crazy
online every 20 minutes put
something it's crazy so my point here my
brothers tell me if I'm wrong if you
want to boycott someone and you I'm
going to boycot them because they are
supporting Zionist why you not
boycotting America why you are using
their passport to travel to
London ah so you happy with American
passport with a passport that represent
the country that are supporting the
Zionist Allah aldah
now
cforia brother if you want to boyot make
sure you boyan first make sure doesn't
mean doesn't mean you should be perfect
all right doesn't mean you should be
perfect meaning that you're not happy
that come back someone told me happy you
came back your word next time I tell you
I come back word I tell you I come
back someone I prom someone last week
he's one the the brother give he told me
can you come this Sunday and I promised
him that's why I come back even though
he didn't
come you don't have a Starbucks today
alhamdulillah no Starbucks no no no
today I'm I'm good Muslim I'm a good
Muslim look Starbucks making me good
Muslim
now step step here step here
why no you got time speak to me leave
leave he did not listen to your
reasoning he did not listen for
names you know he was at home debating
in mirror and when he came here it's
complet different that's why he's hiding
so I told you my brothers if you don't
like me and you don't debate the mirror
I'm not the mirror and it's over there
now it's over there
found a better angle you know what wait
wait s from Ang can't see
him said if you are if you're in the
prayer and thean
comes back so this man this man he
couldn't even speak to me he said I have
he said he has no time for me but I
still has the time to speak to me I
don't understand that I don't understand
even though I clarified why I came back
because s and he will confirm it
everyone
thank you
brother go ahead